I'm Brian Bluyn and I am a cup master with PAC 3285 out of Rockford, Michigan.
This edition of the Scoutmaster podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
And now for you, Scoutmaster.
Hey, we were out orienteering recently with you know how that works: maps, encompasses
and everything.
One of the Scouts was a little overbearing and we needled him about it, but it's fine,
He has a magnetic personality.
Yes, indeed,
This is podcast number 342..
Yes, it's podcast number 342..
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast.
This is Clark Greene.
Let's look in the mailbag.
Doug Wheeler commented on Facebook about last week's podcast, podcast 241, where we're
talking about asking and telling and the way that that works with youth leader development,
And Doug said very simply and succinctly: excellent podcast.
Well, thank you so much.
I heard from Aaron, who's a scoutmaster in Fresno California, said: thanks much for
doing this.
Your insight into scouting has been a tremendous help for me trying to figure out how to
be a scoutmaster.
I just began this role recently, after about a year of transition.
It's nice to see that I was on the right path in some ways and also ways to prevent going
down some of the paths I was about to go down.
Well, we're always happy to help, Aaron,
Hopefully you're not just listening to the podcast, though. right,
Everybody should be reading all the resources and talking to people and doing their best
to be good scouts.
That's what we ought to be doing.
I think most of you are.
I got to speak to. well, not speak to, but chat on the computer with some nice folks
last week.
Now, if you'll keep an eye on our Facebook feed and our Twitter feed, look on that on
Tuesday morning, because around eight o'clock Eastern time, we'll be on with a live chat,
And there's plenty of folks who come around just about every single week sign in to
say hello. but this past week I was happy to hear for the first time from Chris
Spratlin, who's a scoutmaster with Troop 27 in Bartlett, Tennessee.
From Miguel Ciflentes, who's a scouter in Costa Rica, signed in, as did Sheldon
Lehman, who's with the first Waterloo Scout Group in Ontario, Canada,
Edward Steele, who's a scoutmaster with Troop 73 in Bolton, Connecticut,
Brett Bolton, who is a scoutmaster for Troop 508 in Irving, Texas,
And Ted, who's a scoutmaster of Troop 45 in Glen Ellen, Illinois.
They all signed in for the first time on the live chat this week.
Make sure to come and join us.
We have a lot of fun and discuss incredibly serious and useful things,
like the weather, for instance.
Before we get rolling, I want to make sure to thank all the folks
who are scoutmastercgcom backers and patrons.
They're the ones who lend some financial support to all this madness
to keep it all up and running.
We sure do appreciate you.
You can become a backer or a patron too.
Look in this episode's podcast notes or go to scoutmastercgcom.
Just about every page has a link in the upper right-hand corner
where you can learn about the different varieties of support
that you can lend us,
And it's easy to get in touch with me.
I'll remind you how at the end of the podcast,
but I'll tell you right now.
I'm always at Clark at scoutmastercgcom.
C-L-A-R-K-E at scoutmastercgcom.
Well, I have been combing through email.
I think I've got three pretty good email questions to answer,
So let's get started. shall we
Rhyme your letter, send it by name
Email, that is, folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
OK, here we are.
Let's jump into the first email, which- and the sender
will remain anonymous. at their request-
And they sent this-
The parents of our troupe are not happy with our district
or council.
They feel we're kind of outsiders because two powerhouse troops
in the area get more help from the district and council,
because the district and council level volunteers
are largely coming from those troops.
This apparent nepotism contributes to the distrust
of things that the council and the district do.
I am interested in changing this
and I wonder if you could tell me the benefits of working
with the district and the council.
Well, that's a really interesting question.
And I will say this
For my role as a scout master, because that's all I do,
That's the only thing I volunteer for is I'm a scout master,
So district and council stuff kind of plays a relatively
small role in that.
I understand the support that we get from our scout district
and our scout council,
But as far as the way that I have a relationship there,
it's pretty minor.
My focus is making scouting possible for my scouts
and developing youth leaders and things like that.
So the troop committee in my instance
takes on the district and council relationships
From my standpoint. I'm being a little cynical,
but it seems to amount to a lot of frustratingly
over complicated paperwork.
but I'm not a big paperwork guy
if you haven't already figured that out,
So take that with a green assault.
I guess our highest profile interaction
with our district and council
is our summer camp,
because we attend our council summer camp every summer
and getting eagle projects approved
and eagle boards of review, that sort of thing.
Now, years ago I was more involved
at the district and nominally at the council level.
I helped by planning and running some Weebelows weekends
And I believe, if I remember correctly,
a camperee or two for our district.
My wife and I ran an after-school
Cub Scout program for a couple of years
that had some council and district connections.
I worked at our summer camp on the camp staff
for about a dozen years,
with a couple of those years being as the camp director.
So I was an actual council employee.
I've run training sessions.
I guess it's been a long time though
It's been at least three or four or five years-
since I've run a training session.
I think that our Scouts, outside
of our participation in summer camp,
I'm pretty sure they go to events
like a Marripad something or other.
They haven't chosen to go to a camperee
or any kind of district event like that in a long time.
We do have Scouts who are involved in the order of the arrow
and that's probably the highest profile active program
that our Scouts participate in above the troop level.
That just gives you a little bit of context
for what I'm about to say,
because I do know what you're talking about.
when you mentioned that other troops
seemingly benefit from a closer connection
with the district and the council,
I'm not exactly sure what advantages they would have.
Maybe- I don't know- first in line at the banquet.
I don't think that there's really
a giant advantage there. personally,
because I've seen that in the past
and as a younger man I might have been jealous
of some of those associations and things like that.
but now, having traveled the path for several miles,
if you happen to have a troop
with a lot of district or council volunteers
involved with the troop, I guess that's nice.
I don't see a lot of advantage in it
and I certainly don't see anything unfair.
So I guess I would challenge that assumption
because most of the time that perceived benefit
really amounts to the fact
that you just have to have a number of adults
involved with the given troop
filling a district or council volunteer role
and they end up having a whole higher profile
at district or council events
and it could look like they benefit from them
more than others. but I've never really
found that to be the case.
So in the end, I'm probably not being much help
with that- with your particular question-
but I don't think I'm missing out on anything
from the district or the council
and, more importantly, I don't think my scouts
are missing out on anything either.
We've had occasions where we've had district volunteers
who are also adults involved with our troop
and we've had council level volunteers
who are adults involved with our troop.
didn't seem to make a whole lot of difference
one way or the other.
Now I'm not trying to actively discourage you
from finding out what goes on at the district
or the council level. there's likely some good for you
Personally, and maybe even your scouts,
beyond the kind of administrative connection
that you have to the district and the council.
is there anything to be gained
that these other troops are getting
that you're not. probably not,
And I think this is a good opportunity for me to say this.
I'm a one role kind of guy.
There are a lot of people that wear many different hats.
maybe they're a unit level volunteer
and a district level volunteer
and a council level volunteer,
and maybe they're involved in three things at each level.
I'm not into that personally.
Let's wear one hat, occupy one role and do it well.
So, anyway, hope that helps with that particular question.
I don't know if it did, but perhaps it does.
Here's another email, again anonymous
at the sender's request.
I'm a new Wolf Den leader and a professional engineer.
I had completed wood badge
and part of my ticket is incorporating STEM
into Wolf Den leader training
And STEM- S-T-E-M- an abbreviated way of saying
science, technology, engineering and mathematics-
and educational category
that you hear a great deal about anymore.
I- and the person asked this question goes on to say
I also ran a successful STEM event for our Cubs,
but at a district round table
when I wanted to speak about it,
I was told: well, that's Cub stuff, it's not for scouts,
so we'll have that done during the Cub presentation.
So my question to you is: why is STEM so hot right now,
yet considered- quote- Cub stuff, unquote.
Well, thanks for getting in touch
and let me see if I can answer your question,
because I'm- and I should take the opportunity to say here
that I am- not a scouting official of any kind.
I'm just a volunteer scouter.
so I don't speak for anyone other than myself,
and it's been a while since I've been to a round table
or a district or council event.
so I really don't have a handle
on what people are saying about STEM.
I don't know if it's hot or cold,
I don't know why it's being characterized
as something just for Cub scouts.
All I know is what I've seen about the program
and what I've concluded about it myself.
So I'm happy to hear that you, as a Wolf Den leader,
are particularly motivated about STEM
and it has a connection to your profession.
I think that's great
and I'm glad that you've been working
with successful programs
and I'm sure that your Cubs
and their families are very appreciative.
My own take on STEM is: I don't see how it fits scouting.
I see it as another attempt to try to lend relevance
to scouting programs. perhaps
from those who believe that sort of thing is needed.
I don't particularly see the need.
Now the scouts that I work with,
the scouts in my troop, seem to be perfectly happy
with. camping is the emphasis and center of the program.
I don't think we have lost relevance
or connection with our scouts
and they don't seem to be missing
the whole STEM thing at all.
I know that they are interested in those merit badges
and they do them.
We don't do merit badges as a part of the troop program
and I know that they're interested in those subjects.
but my simple take on scouting at any age level
is that we develop character
through the application of the patrol method
and I see my work as a scouter providing opportunities
for scouts to go camping with their friends
and work the patrol method.
I know it sounds simplistic
and I'm sure in some ways, that it is,
but there's an awful lot of complex things
that go underneath the surface when you go camping
and I've talked about them at great length in the past,
so I won't go into it here
and I'm not trying to be negative.
All I wanna say is: look,
labs and classrooms and workshops
are some of my favorite places.
They have been all my life.
I love learning new skills,
I love learning how to work with things,
I love learning the science of things
and I think that's a wonderful pursuit.
I just don't see it as being particularly relevant
to the focus of scouting.
To my mind, it's as discordant as setting up a tent
and going camping in a laboratory
or workshop or a classroom.
You know, I don't say that these two things
are totally divorced.
I'm just saying the important word here is focus right,
Because there are plenty of STEM things
that happen in the course of a camp out.
There are plenty of STEM things that happen
in the course of a scout advancing in rank.
You know, look at the requirements,
look at the things that they have to do.
These have to do with science,
technology, engineering and mathematics.
I'm just saying I don't see a particular need
to focus on those in isolation.
I think they're a great part of the overall package.
You know, the BSA has had many things,
many kinds of programs like this that have been tried
and they gain a lot of interest for a few years
and then they kind of fade away.
Maybe the whole STEM emphasis has a more staying power.
I prefer to stick with what I see
as best serving young people who become scouts,
and that's working the patrol method
and going camping and building character.
and once again, I'm not being negative,
I'm just saying I don't see a whole lot of value
in that particular focus.
And, all that being said,
I'm always happy when I hear that scouts of any age
are happy themselves and engaged in learning,
no matter what the program, no matter what the focus.
This last email comes from Robert,
who's a scout master in Massachusetts,
and he says: I'm feeling a bit down. right now.
The scouts in our troop are aging out
and our recruiting effort is kind of falling flat.
We are doing all we can to encourage weeblos
who unfortunately keep choosing to go to a different troop.
I'm starting to feel that the troop might be doomed.
Oh, Robert, I know this feeling.
I know the feeling because over the past 35,, 36 years
as a scout master I've been through some very long
dry periods with recruiting weeblos.
So I do know how this feels and it's not good.
But before I give you any advice,
I will tell you, as unsettling as it may sound,
that units do have a lifespan.
Troops and things like that do have a lifespan.
We used to have five troops in town
and that dwindled down to two-
almost one- for a couple years.
Now we have three.
The three troops are doing fine.
They each have a slightly different way of doing business.
The two troops that went away were around
for years and years and years and things just happened
And sometimes there's nothing that can be done about it.
You know it's a complex mixture of problems
and changes and logistics and sometimes units go away
And when that happens it's not likely it's because
of one particular person's lack of effort
or that a group of people have done something wrong
or anything like that.
Things just have a lifespan sometimes.
Now I don't say that to discourage anyone,
because I know you're gonna keep on doing all that you can
for your troop.
I say it because you aren't alone
in your frustration with the situation
and all likelihood it's not your fault.
So just in case you're feeling a fault,
don't put that on yourself.
So here's my advice.
I began to understand in one of these
long, dry recruiting periods where all the weeblos
everywhere seem to be joining over troops,
that weeblos are not only
or even the best source of new scouts.
I mean, our informal analysis of new scouts
and how long they last over the past seven to 10 years
tells us that the weeblos that we have gotten
are much more likely to drop out
than the boys who've joined the troop,
who were never scouts.
So at one point we kind of stopped chasing weeblos,
mostly because we weren't getting any-
So it's not like we were getting droves of weeblos-
and we said, no, let's stop this.
We just said that's not going to be
our only emphasis anymore.
We scaled back our efforts in that wise
and we upped our efforts in recruiting all the time
from anybody who was interested in being a scout.
Now we still have plenty of weeblos dens visit
and we have some join now and again
and I think we have three or four coming in this spring.
but when weeblos come to visit
we're very clear about the kind of troop we are
and what our expectations are,
and that there's another troop across town
and you really should make sure to visit them
and see what's going on there.
We're interested in recruiting weeblos.
We just don't put up a whole lot of fight.
So that was kind of. step one was to say, okay,
this is not the only way that you get new scouts.
Step two was understanding that there are two,
and only two, ways to recruit scouts
that seem to work on a consistent basis,
And I think I've talked about this before
but, at the risk of repeating myself,
here are the two ways.
One, scouts talk to their friends who are of scout age.
Two, parents of scouts talk to parents of scout aged boys.
Those are the two ways that work.
So, Robert, in your particular situation,
here's what I would suggest you do:
Get your scouts together
and tell them their challenges
to each identify at least five boys
who they can invite to scouts.
Get the families together.
Tell parents you'd like them to talk
to at least five other families
about having their son join scouts.
Now you and I both know that not every scout
and not every parent is going to come through on this,
but don't pay attention to who doesn't come through
as much as paying attention to who does.
Give them a goal.
The parents need to find five,
The scouts individually need to find five,
And then give them a good call to action
for those boys and parents that they talk to,
and that is, invite them to go on a camping trip,
Not to a meeting, necessarily, but a camping trip.
And it's important to emphasize camping over meetings
because, of course, if they want to go camping,
they're going to have to make at least one meeting
to find out what to bring in such.
That's why I say emphasize camping. meetings will follow.
Then make it as easy as possible
for all these possible new recruits to go camping.
They can be guests.
They don't have to be registered.
Just take them along with as little fuss
and paperwork as possible.
Don't even mention joining the troop.
Wait until they or their parents ask how to join.
I guarantee that the scouts and the parents of scouts
will be talking to them about those particulars. anyway,
I think our message as scouts is: come camping with us.
We'd love to have you come as a guest
and make that as simple as possible.
I wouldn't try to have a big, special camping trip
for visitors. just go camping like you usually do
and make having visitors a habit,
something that happens as often as possible.
See if you can get a visitor
for every single trip you go on.
Don't play too close attention to them.
Let them do what your scouts do
And I'll bet you'll have some new scouts
in pretty short order.
That's a pretty simple approach
And it's one that I know works.
I've tried just about everything else:
Special meetings, special trips, flyers,
things in the school newsletter, school visits,
putting up signs advertising.
none of that has netted us one single new scout.
But I can say pretty reliably:
if a boy who is not a scout goes camping with us,
they will join the next week about 9.9 out of 10 times.
So, Robert, I hope that helps.
Again, it's not your fault.
Sometimes these things have lifespans and things change,
but I hope those ideas will gain some traction
and make a difference for you.
Hey, I'd love to hear from you
if you have a question or a comment,
and I'm pretty easy to get in touch with.
I'm gonna tell you how to do that in just a moment.
["Band Warms Up with You"].
Well, thanks for listening
to this 342nd edition of the Scoutmaster Podcast.
Now here's how to keep in touch.
You're gonna find 1,500 plus articles
and all the past editions of the podcast
at scoutmastercgcom
And you can subscribe to receive updates by email
to every time we put in a new blog post or a podcast.
So I encourage you to do that.
Join us in the vast panorama of social media outlets.
That's right.
We're got tons of folks on Facebook and Twitter
and Pinterest and you can watch us
at ScoutmasterCG on YouTube.
But if none of that makes any sense,
if you're not interested in being social in the media-
I got no problem with that, Bunky-
Just zoom into the late 90s and send me an email.
And if you don't know what email is,
find an 11-year-old.
They'll explain it to you and they'll show you how to do it.
But you can email me clarkgreen
at clark at scoutmastercgcom.
C-L-A-R-K-E- don't forget the E
at scoutmastercgcom.
Now, if all else fails,
go down to the Telegraph Agency in your town, city or Berg.
Tell the Telegraph Agent you wanna get in touch
with Clark at scoutmastercgcom.
It's a little costly,
You have to pay by the word,
So I would suggest the single word help,
because I'll understand exactly what you're saying
And I will get it back to you
with an answer to your question.
Well, by now it should be abundantly clear
that the Scoutmaster blog and the Scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications of anyone other than myself.
Yep, it's only me.
I'm not endorsed by or sponsored by
the Boy Scouts of America,
or any other scouting organization for that matter.
It's me
Talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to Scouters
and maybe have a little bit of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun,
here he is again,
our founder, Sir Robert Baden-Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Why? thank you, sir.
Until next time, everyone.